la perte de biodiversité est telle que
certains scientifiques affirment qu'on
se dirige vers une nouvelle extinction
massive de la vie sur Terre est-ce
vraiment possible de freiner le déclin
[Musique]
alors ça c'est le premier jet du
document qui va être négocié à Montréal
je vais vous lire l'objectif a partir de
maintenant l'extinction posée par les
humains de toutes les espèces menacées
est arrêtée d'ici 2030 à 2050
rendez-vous compte qu'en parle de perte
de biodiversité les chiffres sont
tellement immenses que c'est dur
d'imaginer qu'on puisse arrêter la perte
de biodiversité si on se met tous
ensemble d'un point de vue technique
scientifique est-ce que c'est vraiment
possible de le faire
nous nous sommes rendus à lacsenburg
proviennent en Autriche pour rencontrer
un chercheur qui a répondu à cette
question dans un article très influent
il s'appelle David Leclerc
[Musique]
des deux questions qu'on voulait
adresser dans cet article dans cette
étude c'est est-ce que c'est faisable
d'atteindre un objectif aussi ambitieux
que un verset le déclin de la
biodiversité et si oui qu'est-ce qu'on
peut dire de comment y arriver
[Musique]
la vision de la Convention sur la
biodiversité quelques formuler par les
chefs d'état depuis 2010 c'est de vivre
en harmonie avec la nature d'ici 2050
c'est une vision abstraite difficile à
mesurer c'est pour ça que depuis peu les
experts la reformulent d'une manière
plus scientifique on parle de renverser
le déclin
depuis assez partagé et qui maintenant
au centre du nouveau plan pour la
biodiversité qui est négocié
[Musique]
mais en fait comme pour les changements
climatiques on utilise des modèles
informatiques
ces modèles sont des représentations de
la planète ils permettent de tester les
conséquences de nos choix David Leclerc
et ses collègues ont évalué cette
scénarios cette future possible élaborée
à partir du travail fait depuis des
décennies pour modéliser le climat et
donc ça c'est une figure qui était un
peu plus ces implications de ce
différent type de scénario
parmi ces scénarios le scénario business
as du jour et le plus pessimiste celui
où on ne change rien nos habitudes dans
le scénario intermédiaire on augmente
les efforts de restauration et on
protège plus de territoires le scénario
le plus ambitieux lui incorpore en plus
des modes de production plus durables où
on produit plus sur moins de terre à
cela s'ajoute une réduction du
gaspillage alimentaire et une diète plus
végétale les modèles évaluent ensuite
l'effet de chaque scénario sur l'usage
des sols les terres agricoles les airs
conservées et restaurées
par les modèles pour tous les scénarios
sans ensuite évalués par des modèles
dont le rôle c'est vraiment de relier
cet usage du sol à un état de la
biodiversité
c'est comme ça que les chercheurs
obtiennent un aperçu de la biodiversité
du futur à gauche le scénario pessimiste
et à droite le scénario le plus
ambitieux et les obtiennent un ensemble
de mesures de l'état de la biodiversité
de ces diverses facettes les habitats la
densité des populations animales les
risques d'extinction et plusieurs autres
ces données sont traduites en courbe
puis résumer ici en bas la courbe
d'évolution de la biodiversité business
asieurant avec un déclin d'à peu près
tous les indicateurs jusqu'à la fin du
siècle on aura perdu au passage 54% de
la densité animale au milieu le résultat
d'une augmentation des efforts de
conservation et de restauration on voit
un léger redressement en haut les
approches intégrées ambitieuses elles
permettent de renverser le déclin avant
c'est un message optimiste qui quelque
part dit que cet objectif est
atteignable les parents de porter quand
David Leclerc a publié son article
c'était la première
preuve il est vraiment possible de
renverser la tendance cet article a
suscité beaucoup d'enthousiasme mais
aussi amener une bonne dose de réalité
parce que ce sera pas facile d'y arriver
il est clair qu'on peut pas se contenter
d'augmenter les efforts de protection et
conservation ça ne suffira pas et donc
il faut absolument entre autres
s'engager dans une transformation plus
globale d'un système alimentaire de la
ferme à la fourchette et sans ces deux
facteurs en fait on n'arrivera pas à
inverser les courbes avant 2050 à ses
efforts doivent s'ajouter ceux pour le
climat toutes les études qui prennent en
compte l'évolution future de l'usage du
sol et celle du climat montre que si on
n'atteint pas les objectifs de Paris il
y a de très fortes chances qu'on
n'arrive pas à inverser les cours de
déclin la biodiversité
ces travaux ont rendu les cibles
ambitieuses plus acceptables pour
certains gouvernements parce qu'elles
sont désormais soutenues par la science
aujourd'hui ces données se retrouvent au
cœur des négociations de Montréal
là la vraie question c'est de savoir
est-ce qu'il y a une véritable volonté
politique et ça on ne sera pas avant
quelques mois
[Musique]